i want to get to
a little bit on biden
joe biden
i met joe biden
he was lovely he was very nice to me um
was a different joe biden back then i
don't i don't recognize this person
right now um he's he's changed in some
ways in many ways
regardless didn't know him well back
then i met him i was on the view i
interviewed him but i
something is is different something has
changed did he sniff your hair
he did not sniff my hair i think he said
something to me like i'm a fan i'm a
supporter even though we disagree or
something silly like that everybody says
all democrats say that to a conservative
they're like oh i'm a yeah you know i'm
a even though we disagree you know
something like that he said i'm not
quoting you joe with something that i
remember i told my mom about my mom will
remember she remembers everything she's
right now at home like texting quote
this is what he said don't misquote the
president that's happening right now
live
from the bela house by the
well not anymore never mind i was going
to crack a joke sometimes it's just not
that funny dad tyler's like judd you're
not a comedian stop trying to be one all
right my my girl thinks you're a hoot
she texts me yes really after she goes
jed is a hoot i'm only funny by accident
so that's okay i if i ever had to
deliver comedy
every joke would fall flat i'm funny by
accident usually when i'm
doing something that makes fun of myself
because i'm a hot mess it's clear look
at my hair
did i say more
need i i warned you about the humidity
so people at home that are like
embrace it i'm sicilian humidity does
this it's passionate it's exotic that's
what i go for
all right
daily mail
daily mail to say our country was on the
right track would flagrantly depart from
reality top democrats say biden should
not run for reelection in 2024.
interesting
interesting
top democrats across the country said
president joe biden should not run for
reelection in 2024 as they expressed
worries over his current leadership and
age nearly all 50 democratic officials
interviewed by the new york times
feared a biden re-election campaign
would not help their party against
republicans who are expected to make
sweeping victories in the coming
midterms of course they will
of course they will they'll make
sweeping victories because of the
mandates because
why
because the country is falling apart and
people aren't blind that's why because
when you can't afford to put gas in your
car no one is going to be able to
convince you no things are great
everything's fine but um i can't put no
it's fine
no you're not going to buy it you're not
an idiot you're not an
idiot so first of all
i don't want to say this is good news
from democrats because
lord only knows who they do want to run
instead of biden and it could be
somebody way worse in my opinion like
what was kamala is that who we're
talking about or like aoc or like what
like what
that style not aoc herself but that
style democrat i don't know
so i don't care about that but what i do
care about is one there is an
acknowledgement that he's doing a bad
job he's doing a terrible job um
and i'm just curious people at home who
who are thinking about this
what is going to be the re-election
strategy here
and we can talk about this tyler too
like what what is that going gonna be i
mean i was thinking like oh love
inflation re-elect biden
wanna hunt for baby formula real life
but i mean things are just not and i'm
not saying biden is responsible
exclusively for all of these things but
things do not look good right now
want a forced injection or lose your jaw
vote biden
want to pay 10k for a gallon of gas
vo biden i mean what what the slogans
right themselves
i mean look what's going on at the
border
it's a disaster it's a disaster
so much so that i have people who
friends who live in texas that are like
i don't know man what's going on here if
they're not going to take this seriously
i'm going to pick up and leave
who live by the border southern border
oh mask your two-year-old endlessly
bo biden
i mean what what are the positives here
really if you look at the last
however long he's been in office it's
actually not that long it's shocking the
damage that has been done
not only that people in these liberal
cities are also saying
i don't know man this isn't looking so
good
you know it's fine when we're talking
about woke politics and academia and all
that oh maybe i can get on board with
that but like if i can't walk my
two-year-old to school without worrying
i'm gonna get mugged i don't know man
maybe i'm out on this stuff
so i'm curious what the strategy is
gonna be and i always love
talking point
driven people that come out and you know
they'll have some ridiculous like you
know i don't know build better
part two
and
something right
build back even better or they'll like
trump will say something they'll twist
that and make up a slogan that sounds
dumb i don't know and i don't know who's
gonna run against biden but
people know better right i mean you know
you're sitting at home right now and
you're like
i'm not gonna be able to be convinced
that things are good when i can't afford
x y and z when i have to like
get a second job and i can't when i've
been out of work for x amount of months
because i didn't get a vaccine and he
encouraged these mandates so like you're
not gonna be able to convince people
otherwise so i'm curious tyler
like what are they gonna do
um so
one thing that we didn't mention was
that we left behind 84 billion dollars
worth of military equipment in
afghanistan which we have not seen the
ramifications of so that's still to come
i think but i'm actually so
i think you're right that uh republicans
are going to win the house and the
senate in 2022 yeah i think it's going
to be a sweeping landslide to be honest
with you i don't think it's going to
make a difference i'm not excited by
mitch mcconnell i'm not excited by kevin
mccarthy i'm not excited nobody is just
it's the uniparty yeah nobody is you
know i'm excited that you're seeing
people like jd vance and joe kent and uh
uh
blake
blake adams i think out of arizona who
the peter thiel companion i mean you're
seeing a new faction of the republican
party the conservative party
but as far as 2024 goes i'm actually
deeply worried um i don't know if trump
can win re-election i don't i think
trump is turkey yeah i i the country saw
what he did in 2016. and not so much
what trump himself did but what happened
the trump effect what it did to the
country right my biggest fear is they're
going to run michelle in 2024 because
they have a huge opportunity if they run
the right person
they could blow trump out of the water
no i don't think michelle wants that job
would she be a contender i mean would
she blow things up in a different 100
people love her
and and part of the part of winning is
your beloved right people loved they
liked obama they wanted to sit and have
a coffee with him and that was most of
what was going on there they really
liked him they thought he was a genuine
guy he was likable they liked the way he
conducted his interviews
i think you bring up two two important
points one is that
first of all no one no one cares about
mcconnell
you know no one these these gop
establishment leaders
they're disappointing over and over and
over again i got involved in politics
when the tea party was rising up
and what i loved about that movement was
that it was driven by people and that
movement you know as a reminder was not
a backlash against democrats that was a
backlash against republicans who were
not doing their job
who were not caring about the debt you
know it was the mike lees and the rand
pauls who were like i'm sorry we can't
afford that
um debt was a big issue the deficit was
a big issue low taxes was a big issue
of course they were painted as violent
and i went to those rallies i didn't see
any of that ever i saw a lot of patriots
i saw a lot of people who were unhappy
and holding government accountable i
didn't see any of what was the media
claimed what's happening it's projecting
i mean that all came from occupied of
course i was in new york with occupy
occupy was throwing the feces occupy was
beating the same with the blm protest oh
yeah always projection i was in new york
city when the occupy tents were downtown
and there were like rape tents right and
it was horrible it was that it was
really horrible filthy it was horrible
what they did to new york city really
disgraceful was allowed to go on
but what i don't know what's gonna
happen in 2024 what i will say to
republicans is i think trump is can be
problematic in many ways you know there
are people who've already made up their
minds about him one way or another and
that's you know he's not new
he's done great things he's done things
people don't like some love his demeanor
some hate his demeanor
you know
he sometimes some i always felt like
sometimes i wanted him to get out of his
own way like you did something good now
just let it be good for a hot second you
know me personally other people felt
differently and they were like let him
go let him go but he's he is a very
divisive figure even on the right
i think a lot of what he did policy-wise
was good
ron desantis would be
amazing
i don't know if he wants to run what i
will say to republicans don't run a
weakling this is not the time don't run
a bland like oh this is not your time to
pull out you know the john mccain or the
mitt romney i'm not interested i wasn't
interested then i'm not interested now
this is your time to pull someone who
has a record
who's a fighter
who knows when like let me be quiet
who
doesn't get into a lot of trouble with
media who knows how to own media in a
way
la ronda santos he doesn't know how to
own media he knows how to put them in
their place he knows what he's talking
about he has a a proven record in
florida somebody if not him if he
doesn't want the job and he may not
someone like that
someone who's not going to get on stage
and take garbage that's what you need
and i think there's a there's a good
shot there i don't know what's going to
happen from democrats biden is a
disaster i think they know that kamala
is a disaster i mean short of like
a wealth of videos of her
inappropriately laughing i don't know
what could be gained about i mean i
don't know what's going on there with
the really weird laughing but other than
that not to mention her speeches are
written by children
yeah it sounds like um
someone who's kamala harris often sounds
like someone who is giving a class like
reading their paper in front of class
only like they're not quite prepared
right so i wrote this last minute i
didn't i wrote it last minute i'm hoping
no one realizes i'm just gonna kind of
like
and then when i do something that
doesn't make any sense i'm just gonna
laugh
just cackle i'm gonna cackle
going to cackle i'm going to cackle and
help for the best she she let's not
forget she was the farthest left senator
in congress farther left than bernie
sanders right and she is so disliked by
the american people she couldn't even
get a single electoral vote in
california oh and they'll say it's
because people are racist no she's
terrible right she's terrible she is
terrible if you're paying attention
she's terrible she's not a good
candidate hillary clinton was not a good
candidate
i'm curious where it's going to go but
regardless of where it goes you are not
going to make people unsee and unfeel
what they have seen and felt
you're not going to make people you're
not going to convince the single mom at
home who lost her job as she was say she
was a nurse she lost her job because she
didn't get a jab that you insisted she
get and then she was at home trying to
put food on the table for her kid and
she had to put gas in her tank to go to
the grocery store and it was priced the
way that it is right now
you're not going to convince her that
you did a good job honey while her kids
stayed at home and learned from home and
couldn't right babysitting from the
school essentially that was locked down
with her for two years right while the
child had to be go through remote and
then when did go back into school had to
wear a mask right
right you're not going to convince that
person that you've done a good job good
luck
good luck with the fancy slogan build
back better too
good luck you better have a lot more
than build back better part two in your
back pocket because you're gonna need it
that's this is an interesting question
though i mean
because this this keeps popping up do
they have anybody i mean do they have
legitimately i don't know were they
gonna run chess feeding pete beto who
eats dirt i mean kamala is awful
elizabeth warren is awful
bernie's too old then
in bernie's uh defense even if he did
run the dnc wouldn't let him win
no no they already they already you know
twice they ran him out yeah they already
wrecked his campaign a couple of times
like oh no you're not the guy we want
sorry bernie sit this one out i don't
know i don't know who they have i think
their bigger bigger problem though is
policy i really do because no matter
what that figurehead is right now
they have to deal with reality and
reality for them sucks because reality
for a lot of americans sucks and a lot
of it not all of it a lot of it is
because of their policies if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]